hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
[Music]
oh baby hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast
this is ru garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians
and fun if they grow up classy or if
they're absolute trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day here
gash digital studios in the big studio
in the east village the tornado came
through
we're still [ __ ] standing this
goddamn universe can't take us
out no matter what they throw at us
coming at you from right next to me
my good pal all right he's the guy who
[ __ ] cooks the books in this
operation
he crosses the tees he dots the eyes
he's an idea man ladies and gentlemen
and let me tell you something folks the
next time you're reaching for a best pal
you know the drill you make it a [ __ ]
kippy all right
two six packs for the [ __ ] price of
one give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody
hey gang what's up that intro uh
it keeps coming back like [ __ ] herpes
man jesus christ happy kids love it the
kids the kid
the internet is chattering about
grabbing themselves to get me
uh happy to be here everybody uh some
quick [ __ ] business before we get
started please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
sir uh full video available on youtube
you can subscribe there as well and
also um the most rift the most recent 15
episodes of the show are available
on itunes on every platform wherever you
get right
uh podcast but the full library of our
show
is available on gasdigitalnetwork.com
which you can sign up for
using promo code a-y-g save a buck 50.
save i think it's two i don't even know
i don't know i'm not a numbers guy but
we get back we got to make some money
here we get to wet our beak
a little bit you know what i mean that's
what we're talking about and the people
we have on guest digital network we have
[ __ ] mark norman joe list paul versi
bobby kelly
yeah andrew schultz shane gillis [ __ ]
matt mccusker we got the [ __ ]
murderers rose so go
check it out sign up for a month and
then [ __ ] cancel it i don't care
that's it that's all you got so like all
i got i just [ __ ] give a four minute
sales pitch
comedy podcast plug the website will
yeah here we go
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with us today
he is the co-host of kfc radio on
[ __ ] bar
stool sports ever heard of it the number
four guy on the [ __ ] website when
you're scrolling down
all right he's a young good-looking kid
he's got a little five o'clock shadow
going
i think that's his office word on the
street he's got a pretty decent piece
ladies and gentlemen give us a nice big
round of applause for mr john
feidelberg everybody this is
not my office this is my roommate
he was late on the rent
i am currently in a bus station right
now
john how you doing buddy good to see you
man i'm
so incredibly nervous for this i gotta
tell you
i just showered i just showered before
doing this because i really don't
you could have took the towel off the
door god damn it look at that clean that
[ __ ] place up will you
jesus your parents came they have a
heart attack
look at that that is a [ __ ] single
guy's bedroom right there
what is that right right behind you to
your over your right shoulder
is that some kind of tinactin no the
other way yeah your other
yeah your other right on the shelf
there's like a bottle it looks like
whipped cream but somebody's doing
whipping is that [ __ ] tough acting
tinactin
dry shampoo not mine again not my room
i shoot with dry shampoo that's funny
dry shampoo
and more dry shampoo a lot of dry
shampoo all right guys you guys aren't a
shower household over there i like it
your roommate's into the self-care i
like it that's a [ __ ] point in your
direction
um so john take us back i want to hear
the origin story where you grew up how
you grew up
brothers sisters the whole nine yards
lay it on us brother
oh boy um okay i grew up on fall river
massachusetts it is uh
most famous for um probably lizzie
borden
who uh she murdered her father uh lizzie
borden took an axe gave her father 40
racks
when she saw what she had done she gave
her mother 41. i believe is how the uh
the phrase goes
what is that a nursery rhyme that you
had when you were a kid that's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah keep the kids at fall river in line
i'll tell you that
holy and then i guess my second would be
chris herron
um who uh you know had a little little
issue with heroin in the nba
uh hell of a guy great great guy um
but uh yeah and i have uh
one brother two sisters had to think
about that
one brother two sisters typical typical
suburban childhood growing up what do
what's
what's
fall river like uh fall river again
it's not great um it's a former milk it
was
it was in the in probably in the uh i
don't know what year to be honest
but it was it was a big town for a while
and then mills
business we shipped them all over to
china and so now it's pretty decrepit
pretty awful
um but uh uh actually you know what
just recently our mayor was uh kicked
out of office
because was stealing
tons of money uh he was a huge
embezzlement big uh big documentary
coming out about that
yeah that's not a great spot that's good
points as far as i'm concerned i love a
little embezzlement i love how the
mayor's like this town sucks i'm taking
whatever else it's got
if you don't get into the local
government
how much it's it he's i don't know
exactly how old he is but he's younger
than me
he's like very very young it's he was
like thought of as like this wonder kid
and uh he turns out he was just stealing
everything dude that's [ __ ] fantastic
awesome how else dude if you became
mayor in your 20s
i would have burnt the place to the
[ __ ] ground he's
lucky all he did was steal it's like
real life
[ __ ] ice town from parks and rec like
it's exactly what happened
he just embedded tons of [ __ ] money
it was like it was with um he was doing
it all with like the weed companies too
because it was like oh you want a
license guess what give me 50 grand
he had oh god this guy's the best who
has the [ __ ]
balls for that dude he woke up in the
morning he was just like
what crimes am i doing today he's the
mayor of a
of a lower tier city in massachusetts
and drove like
a mercedes s-class had like a [ __ ]
batman rolex
which like big money and if you are
if you are making a custom rolex with a
batman logo on it you're too young to be
mayor
yes yeah you're too young to have a
rolex i'll tell you that much you
shouldn't have a [ __ ] you should
have a cartoon rolex yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] lame you show up with the
[ __ ] mickey mouse rolex what a
perfect
[ __ ] hike 20 20 something year old
thing to do it's like ah [ __ ] it i'll
get the corvette i'll get the rolex
i mean when you think about it though i
know like when i was when i was in my
early twenties that's when i was getting
like my first credit cards
and i was totally fiscally irresponsible
still paying so that's just like on a
larger scale instead of just [ __ ]
blowing through his [ __ ] mom's
capital one card he blew through the
[ __ ] city budget for a couple of
years
i'll tell you what congratulations to
you for getting a credit card in your
early 20s i
like got one last year for the first
time i'm 30. really dude i took me a lot
it took me a while to crawl out of it
now the funniest thing about me is i
currently have a 500
credit limit that's all they'll give me
doesn't matter
how much i pay when i pay i go on the
app like every couple of weeks and just
try to apply for more credit
and they're like nah unfortunately at
this time you are still a [ __ ] huge
loser
because i had a couple credit cards when
i was in college and just
zero concept of ever even remotely
paying it back
dude you know what happened to me which
[ __ ] me
my parents got me one of those like
emergency credit cards
oh yeah and i and i used it
not as emergencies ever and then my mom
was like oh yeah well we're not paying
that
so i had like thousands of dollars yeah
dude you buy a case of beer with one of
those credits you end up paying after
you pay it off it costs you like four
thousand dollars for a case of beer
after all the interest and penalties and
[ __ ]
i had uh i used to work at macy's when i
was in college
and in order to get the store discount
to 20
discount you had to put it on a macy's
credit card
so i was in college with a [ __ ] with
a credit card
i would just i wouldn't even do laundry
i would just go buy new socks and
underwear
to wear out that night you know what i
mean like a [ __ ] jerk off
and i just settled up with them a couple
of months ago
i saw that clip of you uh on twitter
when you were talking about
when you were you were running the gamut
there letting everyone retire i just
used to let everybody steal [ __ ] yeah
i worked at gnc in college and i would
have friends come in and buy stuff
just so they would so they could come
back and return it so i could get it for
free
that's a real that's a real dirt
[ __ ] dude there's nothing
there's not many people that we talked
to on here that didn't have
some kind of scam or a hustle with
either their high school or their
college job
yeah dude for sure all right this guy
was moving [ __ ] nikes out of the back
mike you're [ __ ] selling stacker twos
on [ __ ] costs
dude all right we used to i used to work
at a hess gas station and we were
dragging we had some
we has gas station that's not even a top
of the line
[ __ ] petroleum company you jerk off
we got the trucks that's pretty
good christmas time they're all lining
up give me a sunoco an exxon
ah that's [ __ ] euro trash you don't
want that
but we used to do this thing with the
with the premium gas you have a coupon
i mean that's all it was it was like we
were [ __ ] in good fellas in [ __ ]
college in high school
dude we had uh my buddy worked at a foot
locker in the mall
and he would run a two for 70 deal where
you would you would give him 70
cash and he would just pocket the
[ __ ] money and you could get any two
pair of shoes you just couldn't get
tim's or
jordans because they had their own
inventory system like those were like
extra
those had like a secondary checks and
balances system so dude we would just go
in and he would make like [ __ ]
you know like three grand in a night
that is
that's the best one i've heard yeah
that's the best i could ever get oh they
all went down like a lot of people left
there with [ __ ] criminal
[ __ ] backgrounds that's too funny all
right so you worked at g and c that
gives us a little bit of a picture we
get a little picture of the town
uh so what's going to happen now john is
kevin and i are going to ask you a
series of questions
regarding your childhood how you live
now we'd like you to answer them
open and honestly and if they spur any
stories please feel free
i'd like to believe that from the the
gas station scam and the [ __ ] pump
and dunk
at macy's you realize that you're
talking to two dirt bags
and that you are in good company yes you
are under oath i may remind you mr
feitelberg
you don't plan on running for senate or
anything like that do you
no cause that one went out the window a
long time ago nice
dude i didn't i didn't make it past 10.
that was no way i was running for senate
who was the guy that just got the
supreme court that they were when they
were grilling
remember he was just having all yeah
he's like we like beer we drank beer i
did have a couple of beers i had some
beers
that's great all right here we go let's
start out with something simple
um now there's two there's a there's a
couple different kinds of garbage okay
we're more of a light-hearted garbage
um and we don't believe that garbage has
to do with whether you grew up poor you
grew up rich
none of that has really to do with it
it's just like the inherent things that
are in you
from your upbringing and your family um
but i guess number one would be what was
the name of the street
that you grew up on i got a good one
highland avenue
avenues are pretty tough in the suburbs
that's classy i like that
i grew up on a highland drive for a
little while
yeah drives are not kennedy's
i it's actually the like honestly it's i
don't think i'm garbage i'm gonna put
that out there real quick
okay i don't think i am i hope i'm not
but
it is like the one street in the entire
town that's like
kind of nice it's like it is
it is the the top of the heap i suppose
okay that's what you would call it all
right
that's where like the foreman from the
mills would live back in
right exactly yeah yeah yeah the guy who
has had like child labor
i worked my way up huh now i'm cracking
heads see
all right uh let's do a standard here
this is a big one on ru garbage uh
single-family home i presume single
villain home yes okay do you have a
garage
oh yeah did you have was there a
refrigerator in that garage
mini fridge upstairs so that it's a
two-car garage
and then upstairs is kind of like a
living room
man cave situation okay and
wow was it a detached garage or a part
of the
the structure detached oh
it's attached to some clean [ __ ] why
didn't you make that your room i would
have pushed to have that as my room in
high school
no because it was like it's where it was
basically
the hook-up spot so you couldn't make it
your room it was like that's where i
hooked up it's my brother hooked up
that's where
anyone got i imagine probably my sisters
too i don't know i've never spoken to
them about it
but this garage okay here's a story for
it
this garage here we go here we go
what i would do after i hooked up in the
garage is
like an adult i would like take my
condom and put it in a gatorade bottle
and i twist one off and then i
i throw it away it's cool when i think
oh that's [ __ ] that's an a-plus move
right there
why who's your my [ __ ] lawn order svu
was she looking through the trash
i better not find any of your [ __ ]
rubbers up there john
my johnny's a good boy but god does he
drink a lot of gatorade
i'll tell you that most hydrated kid in
school
[Laughter]
but my brother he would open the window
and he would just throw his pawn in the
mouth and
so one day one day my dad was shoveling
the front yard or shovel the sidewalk up
front
and the neighbor comes over and he's
like john i gotta talk to you
[Laughter]
dude the [ __ ] listen i'm a scumbag
i pick my butt pick my nose pick my
teeth
the [ __ ] used prophylactic is the
[ __ ] most disgusting thing
in the world dude a rubber out the
window is something else that is a next
level [ __ ] garbage move
and i thought close like he was taking a
crow hop to throw it like i don't
i don't understand how what kind of load
he was doing
but like it's a good throw it's it's far
to get people out there
jesus i thought you were gonna say the
neighbor came over to tell your daddy
thinks your mom's cheating on him
hey i'm threatening all these condoms i
don't know what diane's doing when
you're at work but
dude that's awesome the [ __ ] spot
above the garage i like that
that's like what every kid wanted that's
like oh yeah that's like a clubhouse
yeah
put a [ __ ] fireman's pole in that
thing slide down so
you know what we were getting at with
the second refrigerator what was in
the the college boy fridge upstairs just
sodas and beers
coors lights that's it that's all that's
all my dad's my bala de platas
that's what we and all your garbage
would refer to as the garage fridge
that's a big staple of suburban life you
had to have a [ __ ] shitty fridge
that was stacked with [ __ ] miller
lights or [ __ ] coors lights and
[ __ ] capri suns and ice pops
and [ __ ] ice cream sandwiches for the
kids my dad left them all
he didn't put beers in the house he just
left him out there because he said he
liked
like having to get up to go i i think it
was it
it quelled his drinking a little bit but
he's like i like
to go far to get a beer yeah because if
they're too close he would drink too
many
now did you guys did he know that you
guys were [ __ ] in there [ __ ]
crushing them left and right
yeah yeah yeah yeah he he called it uh
this i didn't know this until i was
older but he called it like
john's love palace
i thought they had no idea i was [ __ ]
in there they definitely knew
they were 100 and would they ever would
they ever [ __ ] with you
if they knew you were up there with a
girl would they come in like john would
they bang on the door
or it was pretty no ah that's see that's
very very
that's awesome dude i used to have to
hook up with my
high school girlfriend in her living
room with her parents like right up at
the top of the steps sleeping
it was [ __ ] nerve-wracking yeah we
played the fast and loose and bluebell
i'll tell you that but still to have a
[ __ ] separate [ __ ] with a door
you'd have a little bit of [ __ ]
warning even if you heard somebody
coming
that's clean yeah right there what the
girl i did in high school didn't have
such a thing
and one time i got like like classic
high school stuff like i got a hand job
under the blanket didn't take my dick
out of my sweatpants
while her parents were sitting right
next to us that was that's
why that's awesome one of the better
orgasms i've had in my mind oh
yeah dude excuse you're [ __ ] walking
a tight rope right there too
john how's the spaghetti it's really
good mrs maloney
i just love this movie so much we're
watching [ __ ]
avatar oh yeah but i kind of i was kind
of attracted to that big blue broad up
there
she was all right that's good getting
hand jobs [ __ ] during avatar
i got news for you my friend that's
pretty [ __ ] garbage
yeah and the gatorade bottle ain't
helping you either
oh that's good i don't want to be
garbage
what you what was the name of the
grocery store that your mom went to
growing up shaw's
shawn that sounds shitty i don't know
i've never heard of shaw's
you gotta elaborate a little bit compare
it to something
uh it's basically stop and shop okay
stop shop
i believe the shaw's is now a stop and
shot but i i think
massachusetts chain i'm not positive um
but it's now a stopping shot
and you don't really have the accent too
bad did you work on that or is it just
fall river doesn't really have the
strong accent
i wouldn't say i worked on it i went to
a boarding school i went to high school
in rhode island
okay um so there i kind of lost a little
bit gotcha
wait how were you finger banging the
girls if you went to boarding school
i did i didn't board there i i was a day
student but it was avoiding
wait you were that close to rhode island
that you could you could go back and
forth
yeah it's only like 15 minutes it's like
fall river is like the last
town in massachusetts before rhode
island that sounds pretty nice
boarding school all right i like that i
like that that's pretty good
pretty pretty good all right i got one
thinking of movies a little bit how many
of the fast and furious movies have you
seen
bonus points if it was in the theaters
i've seen all of them actually no that's
a lie you're [ __ ] garbage
what are you talking about i have not
seen tokyo drift
i refuse to watch it because i'm a
[ __ ] american okay
i'm not watching some [ __ ] toyota zip
around [ __ ] seoul korea i'll tell you
that
more paul walker no dominic toretto no
thank you
yes but i have all of the other ones
i love them dearly that's nice that's
not looking good for you john
i i stood up and clapped
[Laughter]
seven jesus christ
was this a vocational boarding school
that you went to
are you learning how to be a [ __ ]
plumber
some hvac boarding school in rhode
island i think
i think it's the greatest movie
franchise of all time
i agree sheer number wise it's [ __ ] a
huge success
yeah i mean they're good they're okay
movies for what they're good movies for
what they are for sure
they're great for what they are yeah but
if you like them you're trash
for sure the kennedys don't watch the
[ __ ] face of furious movies i'll tell
you that much
under the radar though they have made a
lot of [ __ ] money on those movies
yeah and and you know what no they're
not respected enough
oh boy we gotta clear it out no
you came in here so hard saying i'm not
garbage i'm not garbage
and now you're giving us a [ __ ] 12
star review of [ __ ] fast and they're
furious
holy crap and they're all well reviewed
like by
critics
yeah other dirtbags
and the acting and the cinematography oh
my god
oh all right that's [ __ ] funny i
think we got them
on the [ __ ] ropes now you better play
piano or something
i don't know
all right we got street grocery store
let me ask you this mr feidelberg
how do you feel about the mcdonald's
menu option known as the filet
o fish
he likes it he [ __ ] likes it in here
i don't order them i was forced i've
i've never had one probably until about
a year or two ago
and someone made me try it pretty good
[Laughter]
but it was it was it was shockingly
palatable
it's the best thing on the menu shout
out to the all the boys
making those fillet of fishes out there
today we love you
all right great
[Music]
let's see all right i got one this is
this one we've we've done a while ago um
out of the following jerseys a football
basketball baseball or hockey
what is the classiest one to wear like
if you had to wear one to a wedding
what one would you choose
all right i am i'm not a jersey guy okay
i don't think
a jersey uh i have a car and that's a
lie i have a few jerseys
but like i'd never wear one to a game or
anything like that
i'm with my hat if i had to choose one
[ __ ] hard uh i would yeah
honestly i guess sleeves are a huge deal
so you got to go hockey
yeah if you're going to work for a
wedding you got to have the full arm
covered
go up
well this is a toss-up i think schultz
said to hockey hockey i
i went hockey because it's also it's
also considered a sweater which is a
dress or a dress
article of clothes you know what i mean
you put on a sweater to go get pictures
take your you're at least in a sweater
not a nice one but you're in a [ __ ]
sweater but
that people call it a sweater it is by
no means a sweater
no not even closer dude i was actually
tweeting today
there was an old clip of uh the maurice
the rocket richard is born 99 years ago
today so the nhl tweeted out some old
clip
it's insane that back when they were
wearing sweaters goalies just didn't
have a mask on
oh yeah one of the more i don't think we
appreciate that as a society
i know people stood in yet and had pugs
fired at them and they did
nothing cover their face that shit's
nuts hockey blows my mind even today
with the equipment that they do have
that you're a [ __ ] stand in there as
a grown man with nothing protecting your
fist
punching another grown man while he's
wearing a helmet that [ __ ] blows my
mind
how insane you have to be to do that and
then you give you a five minute penalty
like yeah every other sport
which is long which every hockey fan
will agree like [ __ ] five minutes
you know like five minutes is a long
penalty that since for bashing a man
skull
dude hockey players play it fast and
loose and i [ __ ] love it
johnny what was your first car buddy
uh land rover discovery nice very nice
did you did you put go ahead
i was gonna say it was awful i hated it
it was like it
it broke down every day i started that
car
it was like a single mom who's working
two jobs today
was there any after-market products put
in the car
once you got it did you put a new stereo
subwoofer did you get some
unit or something had it had a stereo in
it
um no subwoofers nothing in the back or
anything like that but yeah
we we popped to do not sound system but
new cd player yeah yeah yeah that's
respectable all that in the car was a
hand-me-down it was it was
somebody else's car and you got it no
no i bought i bought it used uh yeah you
bought it
yeah oh yeah i thought you meant to hand
me down like from like my parents no no
no i got it
yeah now that see that's all respectable
there you go so that's that's some
points
working their way out of garbage that's
nice getting out of the classroom
furious hole
getting out of here you're getting out
of the game i wouldn't peg you for like
a [ __ ]
black honda civic lowered or something
yeah so you could go under a
tractor-trailer on 95.
with a von dutch hat on sideways
my second car was a buick uh
lesabre i think which is my
grandfather's which had
uh uh they call him a suicide uh suicide
handle yeah yeah yeah he lost his hand
so he only had one hand
so i had that thing i was [ __ ] that
car
and billion times better than land rover
that car was [ __ ] up whipping work
with the [ __ ] suicide that's pretty
[ __ ] sweet man my buddy put my
buddies a [ __ ] whack job he put one
on his car like
three years ago just to [ __ ] do it
there's something about that feeling
even when you're leaning back in the car
and you're just making that turn where
you're [ __ ] using the one hand
and the palm of your hand you feel like
a million bucks dude and the car to do
that is a [ __ ] buick those things are
big [ __ ] grandpop cars
that car had the best heating or cooling
of any car i've ever been in my life i
think it's because old people will die
sure yeah dude they got to keep them
cold
dude like the second you get in the car
freezing
my best childhood memories is either
being in my parents car or my uncle's
car
it would be a [ __ ] big sedan just
exactly what you're talking about
maybe a company car and there'd be that
faint smell of cigarette smoke and the
ac would be at like 22
and you'd be in the [ __ ] back why
some baseball game or news radios
on just [ __ ] just out cold
some baseball game that is coming in and
out of service oh
that was the [ __ ] worst love just
fighting through static it was insane
dude
yeah they just like they just sit there
grip the wheel harder and just do
like deal with the static it made the
game more exciting you're like if
something big was going on it was going
in and out you'd be like are we gonna
hear do we gonna hear do we gonna hear
it dude imagine listening to it like
imagine now listening to a static radio
a [ __ ] four-hour baseball game
through static [ __ ] that
okay everybody hated the sound of your
voice
we'll turn up the static all right let's
see
i got one uh have you ever used
the phrases it's five o'clock somewhere
or it's beer 30.
uh definitely
well i don't think i've ever i don't
know
if i did uh it's five o'clock somewhere
but beer 30
for sure in fact i went through a phase
in college where that was the only beer
i would buy
did you know there was a beer called
beer 30. no
it was a it was a purple 30 rack and it
was called
beer 30 and i thought it was the
funniest coolest thing in the world
awesome that's [ __ ] good that's that
ain't too bad dude
it's garbage wait that was the beer
brand was its beer 30. it was the
that was the brand beer 30.
i'm so jealous i've never even heard of
this yeah that's [ __ ] awesome my
stepdad's a big beer 30 guy every time
he cracks one hey what time is it beer
30.
you it's actually worse than i remember
how bad it looks
a purple can purple cans pretty shitty
that's like toilet bowl cleaner comes in
purple cans
sorry go ahead now guys please what are
you gonna say i was just gonna say
something stupid as we say
that's what the whole podcast is don't
worry yeah welcome to the show say
everything stupid that's what we want
when was the last time
you mr john feidelberg or have you ever
puked in an uber
honestly no okay i'm not a big puker i'm
a peer
wait piss yourself when you're sleeping
yeah that night
i don't do you know some people like get
up and like piss in the corner
yeah i don't do i just pissed the bed
but
um i probably i did it
pretty recently but before that it
hadn't it hadn't been in a long time
like i
like let's just let's be honest here i
pissed myself two weeks ago
um
that i devised a plan for how to cover
it up
where i would like if i woke up first
and i'd piss the bed
i'd go get like a water bottle like this
and i'd take the cap off and i would
just tip it over i would
so there wasn't water in it but i would
just like when
a girl woke up i'd be like oh i must
have forgot to put the cap on the water
bottle last night
sorry i spilled my slightly yellow
pea smelling deer park water bottle i
apologize
hey lady you got to change your brita
filter all right
something's wrong with the pipes in this
this is building pre-war what the [ __ ]
what is this a [ __ ] dasani what's
going on here i need a bowling spring
dude that's [ __ ] genius that's a
garbage move
oh it's a big garbage that's a big piece
of trash move dude i'm sorry
that's a tough one to come back if you
pee in the bed you say hey sorry i
pissed myself
but to devise a plan of finding an empty
water bottle
fake thumb then he like he's like you
know he's she's sleeping he's like
trying to elbow to wake her up a little
bit
like ah he's like stretching too much
and stuff to try to wake her up be like
ah did you spill this bottle
this guy came on here [ __ ] so
defensive
yeah thank you i'm not god tell you
right now let me tell you what i do when
i [ __ ] in the bed
that's [ __ ] genius man i love that
yeah you know it's funny like fights
with like girls and being like no you
pissed the bed knowing full well i
pissed that just like crazy food
ending arguments about who pissed in the
bed knowing it was me
dude you [ __ ] deny it till the end i
don't care what it is
i don't care if the feds are closing in
on you you were with your kids all night
you don't know what's going on
[ __ ] that but that's an interesting
thing you bring up and there is some
kind of psychology
because there really is there's three
different people there's the pukers
all right there's the people who pee the
bed and then there's that
weird [ __ ] group which i'm kind of in
or
i know what happened to me once is the
[ __ ] they go and pee
somewhere weird in the middle of they
pee somewhere that they
think it's a toilet i know but that's
such a weird
thing it's always a stationary object
like an end table a tv
the hamper it's always something it's
always the hamper
i one time one a friend this is a high
school party
i watched a friend get up he was
sleeping on the couch
there was a girl passed out on the um on
the uh
air mattress i watched him get up
thinking he was going to the bathroom
and he just
directly on to her and then he's like
like
shook it afterwards like yeah i've never
seen it before like witnessing someone
thinking they're at a toilet
and like he like shook it and did the
whole pe situation
and then just laid back down and somehow
she didn't wake up
and telling her in the morning that she
was covered in piss
that's not one of the exercises yeah i
was cause i was gonna ask you have you
ever witnessed that like have you ever
it's weird when you see your boys doing
that dude my buddy did it
weekly we after about 12 course lights
his brain shut down and he would fall
asleep on the couch and get up he peed
on my mom's tv
peed on a table that's great i've seen
girls do it too that's even weirder
they'll like just squat in the corner
yeah i've never seen a girl
mom's a hell of a lady ma if you're
listening i'm sorry
shout out to patty huh playing as fast
as loose
in the corner the gall girl is a great
move
[Laughter]
holy dude that water bottle trick that's
[ __ ] great
with that one in the bank yeah it's
because dude
you know what lying through your teeth
is [ __ ]
more is better than that feeling of when
you because i've pissed a bed when you
wake up
and like they gotta clean it up and it's
like the sheets are going in
and you're hungover you just want to get
breakfast that shame is [ __ ]
brutal oh it's it's the word
people always talk about the shame after
you finish watching a porn
i never got
waking up what did i do if i if i did
that what the [ __ ] else did i do
what's going on the tax i've actually
devised
multiple plans to deal with my
alcoholism yeah i'll come right there
with you buddy
the morning texts i'm so good here's a
trick
right you cross your eyes when you open
the text message app
cross your eyes and then you can delete
them all without without focusing on the
words
without focusing on the words you can
still see the red box but you don't have
to see the words that you sent
yep and it's one of the more genius
moves i use
definitely have done that i like that
that's all about you feeling better
[ __ ] the person that got the thanks
i have no idea what you're talking about
yeah
[Laughter]
i got a leaky broad over here the thing
about
the thing about convincing it's not even
about lying that you peed in bed the
fact that you're lying about you not
peeing that is one thing
but then a byproduct of that lie is
convincing this woman that she peed the
bed
yeah so like she's walking out of there
like did i [ __ ] piss
what am i doing i gotta rethink my and
then meanwhile you're just like throwing
the condom out in a gatorade bottle and
getting a break
she knows full [ __ ] well i don't know
feidelberg is the one that pissed the
bed they're just stunned by the fact
that
holy [ __ ] this guy's taking it so far
and then they just leave it alone but
they
know they know yeah they deep down they
know
it's like a 50s marriage we're gonna
sweep this under the rug
john would you say that you're a uh just
a two part question
are you a yearly subscription guy or are
you month to month
what's your move um
[Music]
for what just in general or let me say
it this way
are you a minimum payment guy or are you
a remaining
balance guy i'm a minimum payment guy
i'll be honest with you i'm kicking the
can down the road
i would say i'm i mean like i don't
really know
i if there's a yearly option i'll
probably take the yearly option
like for the athletic subscribe to the
athletic they just charge you yearly
which is great and then but then like
netflix and hulu on month to month
if you give me a year option i'll take
you here
that's smart that's smart that's very
classy i want to give that to you right
there
there that's a [ __ ] good that's a
gentleman's move
i don't do it because i might die
mid-month and i don't want i don't want
them taking the full 15. you know what i
mean
i'll see you on the 29th when i
subscribe to porn sites
okay you usually go what
when i subscribe to porn sites it's
usually like a three month one
okay because you don't want to think
you're going to be a creep in six months
yeah
right right i'll do a thing with like
like basically like
uh probably like i would say it's like
semi-annual maybe twice a year um
i'll like get drunk and be like i'm done
with pornhub
i'm gonna i'm just gonna get a browser
subscription like i've watched
all pornhub has to offer let's see
what's behind the paywall
and then i'll i'll usually first of all
if all i don't know if anyone's here
subscribed before it always gets flagged
as uh
uh a unusual charge on your card yeah
you will have to talk to capital one and
explain to them
i'm just checking out the new abella
danger video um
i'm doing research i'm interviewing
sasha gray this week i'm doing a little
research
cut me some [ __ ] slack that's funny
i've never i'm surprised you say that
i'm not i do you
sign up i never i just do the free stuff
if if i look at porn i look at i look at
the free stuff you go all in on
subscriptions and everything
like like i said it's it's rare but it
probably for like um
probably for like two months a year the
month would be separate sure i i
like going all in and i'll tell you what
it's worth it man it really is it shows
you the things that you're missing that
you don't know you're missing
but once you see it you're like well
like brett so my buddy used to get
uh he was like really into text so he
would get us for our birthdays every
year he would give us
a password like he would be like oh
here's this name and password that i
found or so i don't know
they're all [ __ ] what's going on but we
would get them and
well like browsers is like 27 sites or
something like that right you get
bill funner you get gill funner you get
all you get the whole [ __ ] gamut
dude sharing a porn site password with
your buddies
is a dangerous game sure
we had one b uh my co-host kevin kfc and
then another kid in the office we got a
pornhub premium account
and we were sharing it and then because
you get
the like the recommended for you and
then yeah
which is based on you know two weirdos
what
well yeah i'll be like dude who was
watching just like
chubby amateur hand jobs
[Laughter]
it was like every morning i don't know
who's watching but i'm listening
that sounds like an art house film to me
was that in tribeca i like that that's
chubby i'm jumping up a little bit just
here and there it was probably you with
[ __ ] the avatar fetish that's who it
probably was
[ __ ] sweatpants feidelberg over there
oh that's too good ah okay
all right and i was gonna ask you before
but you already answered i was gonna say
do you call it a laundry basket or a
hamper you call it a hamper huh
what a hamper that's garbage my friend
big hamper family too over here
big hamper yeah hampers trash
i got three of them in my house put it
in the hamper
yeah hampers yes i don't know that
what about this one just to follow up on
it do you call it a vacuum
or a sweeper well there are two entirely
different things i call it a vacuum
i call it a vacuum okay people in your
family called a sweeper yeah we don't
call it a vacuum it's called the sweeper
my mom just bought a brand my mom just
bought a brand new
1200 electrolux sweeper
that's what they call it you guys really
are mountain people that is
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
go get in the steering wheel i've never
heard of call of sweeper either
all right that's good i'm just telling
you
that there is an option you know what it
is garbage and the gentleman passed the
test he calls it a vacuum cleaner
gang just a quick reminder that today's
episode is brought to you by the good
people at sheath
underwear sheath uses moisture
weakening technology to create underwear
that keeps everything breathable and
incredibly comfortable
for you and yours downstairs
these guys are the absolute best i'm
wearing them right now
and i [ __ ] love them she smart
underwear comes in a number of different
styles
including a brief with a dual pouch that
makes sure
it keeps your balls feeling good keep
feels like they're floating around on a
cloud
while you're working out you can't beat
it or if you're just walking around on a
hot day
you want to have sheathed underwear
everybody it's like an inverted kangaroo
pouch for your joey
that keeps your junk from sticking to
your legs sheath underwear was invented
by a soldier while serving in iraq
where you can imagine the balls tend to
get a little hot
in the desert he developed a prototype
in iraq
raised money on kickstarter to launch
sheath now who doesn't want to support a
veteran
sheet underwear is absolutely fantastic
and now
you can support our show yeah it's
awesome i love this stuff they sent us a
whole bunch of pairs they sent some for
the big man
i wear them whenever they're clean i
wear them they're my favorite pair of
underwear
they separate the frank and the beans
sometimes you don't you don't have to
use both pockets if you don't want to
it's awesome so please support our
sponsors because our sponsors keep this
show going
support sheath and they'll support you
when it counts downstairs
bottom line sheath creates amazing
underwear and if you don't love them
they have a hundred percent money back
guarantee off your first pair so give it
a shot so go
get your new favorite pair of underwear
by going to sheath underwear dot com
and use code garbage for 20 off your
order
they ship anywhere in the world one more
time that's sheath underwear.com and use
the code
garbage for 20 off now back
to the show you know what was [ __ ] a
real class
um was my neighbor had one it was the
vacuum system that was throughout the
house
you just plugged the tube into the wall
and it was just
saw i don't know i didn't know what was
going where it went [ __ ] in the
neighbor's yard or something
yeah have you ever seen that do you know
what that is i've seen
it and i think it's actually i think
there was a time it was class
and i think now i think now it's garbage
because now it's like
an archaic relic of like the 70s 100
i'll give you that
i'll give you that but back in the day
that was like having a dumb waiter or
something that thing was [ __ ] a-okay
[Laughter]
a dumb waiter i always wanted a dumb
waiter in my house
i would have been too scared too many
horror movies involve a [ __ ] dumb
waiter
no boy all right i got one have you ever
owned a scarface or sopranos poster
no okay definitely no supporters i don't
think scarface i'm going to go
i'm going to go up 99.9 no 100 sure i
don't know i've never had this
good answer because that is there is no
coming back from that
especially if it doesn't i did have like
the college like the
john belushi two girls in black and
white kissing
because like that's what you did at that
time lesbians were cool like that was
hot
yeah lesbian that's if you're watching
lesbian porn now you got a [ __ ]
problem
but i loved it back in the day that was
i love lesbian porn yeah it's my
favorite no oh
no way really still all right i'm not a
premium gold member of [ __ ]
newport i'm a casual shopper
i don't know anything that i'm not i
love two beautiful women going at it
you know i i like that turns me on i
don't know why
hey i'm not on [ __ ]
this kid's grilling me all of a sudden
that's [ __ ] funny have you ever been
arrested at a sporting event
uh no ever ran out
putting time out yeah what's that a
patriot
a cop just made me sit indian style for
like 10 minutes while he just
i don't know what he thought would be
that's the [ __ ] greatest thing i've
ever heard in my life
i was i was trying to turn a tailgate
into the
preakness and i was just throwing full
beards
and like no one was reciprocating and
the cop was like hey
down you you need to type you're in
timeout you need to relax for a second
and i sat down and just that was it and
i was like
there's pop watch going out ten minutes
he's like all right you can go now like
i did zero up in those ten minutes but
ah that's [ __ ] a funny move it's like
putting the dunce cap on him
go sit in a corner jerk off he makes you
do two laps around the stadium
silla final bird suicides now
have you ever ran out on the field
never no no okay that's good that's
correct
three times four times but they were all
non-stun sporting events
okay uh i get a rid of people on brady
once
yeah yeah yeah you got arrested for tom
brady
yeah during deflategate we all
handcuffed me like three co-workers
handcuffed ourselves in the uh in the
lobby of nfl headquarters demanding to
speak to roger goodell
wow how you call them co-workers they're
co-defendants
did brady ever reach out to you yeah
no he said oh wait yes
they never reached out personally but he
did it was like the
five year anniversary of it this year
this past march
um and he like quote tweeted it and was
like thanks to the support fellows or
something like that but he's never
actually reached out i mean that should
be a couple of [ __ ] tickets or a
[ __ ] something a sweatshirt or
something
tom brady let's go at least a kiss on
the lips tommy if that was michael vick
we would have got a couple of [ __ ]
jerseys out of it at least i would think
huh interesting i'm assuming this is a
yes but we've we've done this a couple
of times have you ever tailgated a
sporting event and not gone in
just going to the tailgate to get tuned
up
and when everybody you know wow okay
i've gone without tickets before yeah
and then usually once i get applause i
end up scalping a ticket yeah
but i i don't think i've ever gone i
forget
i don't believe so i did it at country
fest once um
like a kenny chesney concert at gillette
one time i went to that
gate and didn't go into the concert but
i think i think i've gone
into all the sporting events i've gone
to it's always a real sad walk away when
everybody's heading into the concert or
the
[ __ ] everyone's like high-fiving
can't wait to get a hot dog and you're
like oh yeah just waiting for the just
get a taxi around does the bus run this
way i'm gonna hang out with the skells
in the parking lot for a little while
see if i can find a lot lizard over in b
once that game starts man that place
turns into no man's land
you don't want to be out there holy we
used to go to philly game
phillies games just for dollar dogs we
wouldn't even watch the game we just go
in and get the hot dog we go in at the
seventh inning
just get hot dogs eat like five hot dogs
each and go back out to the parking lot
ah you're [ __ ] trapped
real dirt [ __ ] i'll tell you what i
don't know what they put in those hot
dogs
down at citizen bank park but they are
[ __ ] delicious
shout out to hatfield keep them coming
they are fantastic
did you say kenny chesney hold on did i
hear kenny chesney
kenny chesney yeah i give him credit
though that he didn't go in he just went
out in the [ __ ]
good times when you're in your 20s a
good time is a good time regardless of
what it is
are you a kenny chesney fan uh you like
new country
i don't i do like new country i i i like
it than i used to
there was like probably like in my early
to mid 20s
i was a huge new country guy um
i i like it less i don't really listen
to it much anymore
but i don't even listen to music anymore
i'm i'm a fan of silence
yeah yeah you know it's funny you say
that um those are a lot of garbage
points though you got the [ __ ] fast
and the furious
you got the new country the gatorade
it's stacking up against you
but i respect that what you just said
because i feel like that too man it's
like
and i don't know if it's like i get real
emotional when i like because i'm a real
i have like a really poppy ear like i
want to hear the hits
and it either like makes me real happy
and then there's a drop off after it
or i'm listening to [ __ ] otis redding
and i get real [ __ ] sad
i am kind of over it's called mental
illness [ __ ] wacko
jesus christ go talk to somebody this
guy can't
make it through a [ __ ] playlist i
like it
silent yeah he said i like silence you
go i listen to katy perry and weep
[ __ ] you fat dummy california girl
shout out to katie good luck with the
baby
speaking of uh hot dogs i'm going to
offer up some information
that might be bad for me
you're a ketchup on hot dog guy yeah
i'll pop ketchup on my hot dog
100 times out of 100. now is that the
only condiment that you're putting on it
or is that
in an array uh it would
yeah it's usually the only one but if
i'm at a ball game say then i'll [ __ ]
load it up because now okay i'll get the
onions
i'll get the relish i'll get the mustard
i'll get the ketchup i do the whole
shebang
but if i'm at like a barbecue and
there's not chopped onions available
just straight yeah i take a lot of [ __ ]
for this and i'll share this with you
john cause you're being open and honest
my mate he likes hot dogs
[Laughter]
don't tell nobody coming out of his ears
no i'm
i put mayo on my hot dog i'm a big male
1
if there was available i'd be 100 in
with you
thank you buddy get the mayo there
a lot of people are a lot of people half
the country has a staunch opinion on
putting ketchup on a hot dog
i quite frankly don't give a [ __ ]
because it's a hot dog yeah whatever
it's like already you're eating like the
[ __ ] snout in an [ __ ] who cares if
you put a little ketchup on it to get it
down yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] we'll do it you know
those food elites
can [ __ ] take a hike i i think
mayonnaise
isn't this again this might be a garbage
take
i think mayonnaise is an incredibly
underrated condiment i think mayonnaise
should take
on everything yes you know this guy
should be [ __ ] running for mayor of
fall river
what the [ __ ] going on here i like
what this kid has to say
okay you're absolutely right and it's
[ __ ] very european
and people used to [ __ ] on putting
[ __ ] their fries in mayo
now everybody's [ __ ] doing it no he's
just trying to get on your fidelberg's
just trying to butter you up with mayo
he saw a big man goes he might take it
easy on me if i start talking about
[ __ ]
fat condiments and the next thing you
know hottest vital bird guys you'll be
running for mayor
listen he's on [ __ ] trial here all
right
are you are you were you a hellman's
family or were you a miracle-whip family
hellman's yeah like a true [ __ ]
red-blooded america there you go
not that commie [ __ ] [ __ ] miracle
web
salad spread whatever the [ __ ] you're
putting on it yeah that stuff stinks
all right i think i got a couple more
here oh i got one
um let's call it it's a hot summer day
not unlike today you're standing on the
old street corner in new york city
looking for a nice treat and the ice
cream truck pulls up what do you
order feidelberg choco taco oh
nice [ __ ] now what if it's dinner and
a dessert
what if it's the what if it's not the uh
the suburban uh ice cream truck but the
but
the regular one if would you get a mr
softy what would you do there
if it was actually you get the soft
serve if you got it
chocolate vanilla swirl for sure yeah
but a choco taco
there's something about it's the choco
tacos and then the um
what are they called the other things
that came in the cone with like the you
kind of peel the top off the drumstick
drumsticks drumsticks there's something
about i
i guess it's probably just a stale ice
cream cone
it's not the freshness than a regular
one
yeah it's just like chewy it's [ __ ]
unbelievable
yeah it's not dry like the other ones
are so dry i feel
like you got a fresh one it's like
[ __ ] cardboard a lot of people [ __ ]
on the choco taco which i don't
understand why because when i was a kid
it's like the yankees like this it just
has like an award to me
only you could equate the [ __ ] choco
taco to the yankees dude it was huge
like i'm older than you guys i'm 44. so
i remember kind of when the choco taco
started [ __ ] popping off
all right it was always maybe 75 cents
more expensive than everything else on
the [ __ ] menu
so you seldom got your mom it's an
import it's coming from mexico you
seldom got your marathon
my mom would never [ __ ] fork over for
it so it became like this lore this
legend
and it had that space-age silver [ __ ]
packaging
you had to get your [ __ ] hands on it
and finally when you did it didn't
disappoint
because that is like seven layers of
[ __ ] deliciousness right there
honestly i haven't seen someone speak so
passionately about something
in a long time and i respect how
[Laughter]
i like the way you think my friend okay
he's gonna be talking about it for the
next three hours you're over there
what are you getting a [ __ ] screw
ball huh [ __ ] ninja turtle face
no there's only a handful of acceptable
answers soft sir if soft serve is there
you get soft-serve soft-serves
hold on i'd like to say unless you're
allergic if you don't get a twist
you're not a [ __ ] gentleman you get a
twist you don't get vanilla you don't
get chocolate
you get a [ __ ] twist and you don't do
the dipping [ __ ] you get some
sprinkles like a gentleman
no you mean you know that you're you're
spot on
good bottom knows his way around an ice
cream truck
no uh firecracker
if you're if it's july 4th weekend you
can do a firecracker you're in the red
white and blue yeah
oh yeah come on a chip witch of course
yeah which is great and a choco taco
yeah there's not much
you know you can't do the ninja turtle
you can't do the screw ball you can't do
the baseball glove
those kids sometimes sometimes i get a
little [ __ ] uh
i'd get a little crazy with it i go
italian ice sometimes that's respectable
i like that i like it you want to let
your hair down a little bit
it's friday somewhere oh am i right
i also like the snow cone from the from
the ice cream truck
even though it takes about three days
till you can [ __ ] eat it it's
trash no it's okay it's trash that's
[ __ ] dude it's like chewing a [ __ ]
baseball and i will say the baseball
glove
that's not that bad i don't put that in
the same category as the spongebob
squarepants [ __ ]
because but then when you get to the gum
the gum is just like you're just eating
a wrap exactly
yeah multiple teeth due to that [ __ ]
yeah yeah you got it as a child
because there was gum and it was in the
shape of a baseball mitt that's the only
reason you bought it
you weren't you did it cause you liked
baseball it wasn't a [ __ ] good
dessert
true bottom of the barrel ice cream
trash okay
well we all found common ground in the
chocolate chocolate
i gotta be honest i'm an idiot and for
the longest time i thought there was
really taco meat in there
i swear to [ __ ] god i'm not until
like
way too long way way i remember my buddy
got one i'm like dude
you're eating [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
gross dude and like
they thought i was joking about how
frozen the ground beef
i gotta be honest it doesn't sound that
bad to me all right you're losing
wow all right we're gonna let you get
out of here in a second kippy you got
anything else what do you got
uh i'll do one more because we're in
food and let's hit them with the quick
uh you know the quick uh
absolute regulars um do you prefer
curly fries or waffle fries and there is
an ant there is a correct answer to this
wait hold on
that's not the only option is it between
them okay
curly fries or waffle fries curly
100 oh no no
take that [ __ ] [ __ ] back to fall
river yeah now hold on i'll give
i'll give you a regional handicap on
this are the curly fries big
up there in massachusetts i don't think
so
yeah i think they're i don't see curly
fries a lot i like rarities
i like things that that aren't on menus
often that's a little exquisite
i i'll see that because that's where
that's where it comes
the availability and i feel waffle fries
are the less available of the fried
but you think so i think curly fries i
agree with you
curly fries would be more rare than a
waffle
there's only one place i know you get a
curly fry and that's [ __ ] orbeez
yeah there's one place you get waffle
fries and that's chick-fil-a no they
have waffle fries at other places curly
fries in other places too i can't name
them neither can you
you [ __ ] idiot i can but you guys
might not know them
i actually i don't care for french fries
in general to be honest i'm not i'm not
a big french fried guy
which is a crazy stance i know but i'll
like if i'm going to like a fast food
place
i'll get two burgers instead of a burger
and fries hey i respect that by all
means
do you that's that's that's that's
a-okay i respect that
burger something like that i like the
fried the fly doesn't last
long it goes like bad so fast
yeah you can you you need to eat french
fries right away
or else you're [ __ ] absolutely [ __ ]
there you go
i think it's gonna happen i think we're
gonna start a revolution here
get two burgers get a burger and chicken
sandwich get a burger and a wrap maybe
if you're mcdonald's you get the
little chicken wraps there's plenty of
stuff to do that you don't have to do
the french fry
i like it i never thought about it that
way it's pretty [ __ ] solid i'm sure
big potatoes hurting these days
with the teeth baked potatoes are losing
with the keto and this and that and the
other thing
they asked me the heart it was like that
report uh
that like they're like just throwing out
millions of potatoes because
[ __ ] restaurants aren't open anymore
so that no one's buying no one's buying
french fries
yeah let's keep that energy going let's
keep it going
down with the fries let's stay on foo
here we're going to hit you with two of
the
to the are you garbage staples before we
let you get out of here
um three actually uh number one would be
growing up
was it customary in your house for the
children to drink
milk with dinner that's milk with dinner
john
did you drink milk with dinner big milk
household
yeah [ __ ] vital berg
all right i guess kids all right i got a
follow-up do you still do it
i don't do it as often anymore but i
still like a nice glass of milk with
dinner
a milk and a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich oh come on
of course dude this kid's [ __ ]
chicken what kind of milk we thought
whole milk
two percent two percent there you go
title the road guy
don't [ __ ] with skim do you no heaven
yeah
that's right skim is for [ __ ] [ __ ]
and europeans
get out of here take that [ __ ] back to
denmark or whatever the [ __ ]
the same [ __ ] parry all right hit the
bricks
all right okay um next one it's a big
thing here on are you garbage now this
is a trashy move we'll see what your
family did
was the butter in the refrigerator or
was it left out on the counter
counter that's no good he's [ __ ] two
for two just so everybody's keeping
score
it was in like a nice in the container
of course
yeah or whatever but like so the butter
like if it wasn't the one that was
actively being used
it was kept in the fridge sure but the
one that like where it's used
that's the way to do if you leave it in
the fridge it's too [ __ ] hard you
can't spread it on anything
you gotta let the air get through it
that's my stance is hard it's trash to
keep it on the counter
but the through the fans and all of the
guests i'm being proven that
i'm being told that i'm wrong so i have
to adjust my stance on the butter in or
outside of the fridge
which i'm not happy about but i'll do it
and the last one i wanted to ask you i'm
going to switch it up here uh you could
you could do this now
you're you're a young guy you got your
own place if you have eggs in the house
and you make eggs
okay and you have the carton out the egg
that you cracked do you put the old
shell
back in the container and leave it until
all the eggs are done
or do you throw each individual shell
out as you go
you just throw them out individually
that's great
well that called me crazy john
[Laughter]
your eyes started squinting like what
the [ __ ]
that is the non-garbage answer however i
[ __ ] put them all in the container i
do too
it's a garbage move why do you do that
i'll tell you why because we're [ __ ]
irish trash yeah we're from heavens
um we're [ __ ] derelicts no
because the uh my trash can is
in comparison to in respect to the stove
where you're cracking the egg and
putting it on the pan
is on the other side of the kitchen so
you turn around it like leaks
it causes a mess so i just started to
[ __ ] somebody else showed me that
trick too you just
throw them right in there and put it
back in it's
not track i get it sure but also like
i've definitely done that before where i
put it back in there but then before i
put that back in the fridge i go over to
the trash and just drop them in that's
very respectable yes
i on the other hand am garbagious
unfortunately i don't think the eggs are
gonna
save you in the court of public opinion
uh kevin what is your uh what are your
thoughts on this if i had to put a
number on it
i would say like 68
garbage he's got some good stock i'm
sure his parents are good they got the
detached garage which is [ __ ] clean
but then you got the [ __ ] purple beer
the [ __ ] fast and the furious
catalog the condoms the condoms the
water
the paying the bed that's a that's a lot
of [ __ ] blemishes in the file
don't worry tough one
but don't look at garbage as a bad thing
garbage is a great thing that means
you're a [ __ ]
solid salt of the earth person and i
gotta tell you even though it's a
garbage move
you really did a number on me with the
[ __ ] pouring the bottle of water to
cover up the pee
i [ __ ] give you a lot of that is
[ __ ] i'm telling every diabolical i'm
telling all my little cousins who still
pee to bed i'm telling everybody
to pull a [ __ ] feidelberg the next
time the next time they went to bed
i'll sit him down and tell the story hey
there's a guy out there named john
feidelberg
told me this story it might save your
life one day kid
good stuff john thank you so much for
sitting with this yeah mmm uh
yeah i'm gonna go with kippy 70 80
percent garbage but the best kind of
garbage there is
we had such a good time with you yeah
i'm solid being 68 to 80. that works for
me
it's shockingly accurate
[Laughter]
that's funny john anything you want the
folks out there to know anything you got
coming up
no nothing at all just kfc radio
it's kfc radio yeah you got it brother
well thank you so much for tuning in
uh thank you so much for joining us
kippy what do you got the folks out
there need to know
again just itunes rate review subscribe
youtube you can subscribe as well and
gas digital network to get all uh the
full
uh catalog of shows check it out gang we
have a lot of um
extra content that we're gonna be
putting out there we want you guys to be
all to be a part of it
keep those numbers going up on um on
youtube
subscribe on itunes just like kevin said
thank you to everybody out there in the
live chat for sitting in with us
uh dylan our producer joey the irish our
intern joey thank you
and john [ __ ] awesome buddy thank you
so much for tuning in and being with us
man
thank you very much for having me guys i
appreciate you you got it brother
i'm safe later guys we will see you next
week thank you
peace